if you can solve all three puzzles then  you are a genius or so they say puzzle  one five plus five plus five is equal to  five hundred and fifty move one hexagon  to make the sides equal  the solution is to turn the plus symbol  into a four so we have 545 plus 5 is  equal to 550. you could also have 5 plus  545 is equal to 550.  puzzle two if Eli is 173 and Lois is  5107 how much is Leslie the solution is  to rotate the word 180 degrees so Eli  becomes 173 Lois becomes 5107 and Leslie  will become three one seven five three  seven  puzzle 3 what comes next Arrow fish 8  bridge and table on Circle  take the digits one through five and  then take their mirror image and  superimpose them on top of themselves so  the next digit will be six we take its  mirror image and we superimpose it so we  get this symbol